a new york cette fois les cérémonies
vont se succéder toute la journée à
ground zero où les noms des victimes
vont être égrenés par leur famille six
ans après les attentats le site
ressemble aujourd'hui un vaste chantier
la fameuse tour de la liberté et trois
autres gratte-ciel s'apprête à sortir de
terre le lieu accueillera aussi un
mémorial du 11-septembre portage de nos
correspondants martin laroche joubert et
patrick geoffrion
six ans après les attentats du 11
septembre
difficile d'imaginer à la vue de ground
zero le site des tours jumelles
s'effondrent et les gratte ciel du futur
pourtant les maquettes affiches les
animations éblouissent la flèche de la
tour de la liberté défi le ciel nous
sommes en 2012 en attendant des armadas
d'architectes peaufine les plans sous la
direction de larry silverstein
l'ancien propriétaire des tours jumelles
toujours le patron aujourd'hui c'est un
projet colossal est très compliqué il
nous faut du temps pour le réaliser
autre promesse de jours meilleurs dans
ce quartier meurtri l'ouverture récente
du premier magasin de grand luxe
français c'est un quartier qui devient
de plus en plus résidentiel d un
quartier qui où les new yorkais essaye
de ramener une activité et est
rapidement on a pris la décision c'était
il ya trois ans et voilà nous voilà
aujourd'hui en train de rire ce magasin
en face de wall street on est très fiers
la station de métro fonctionne aussi
dans la différence apparente soul world
trade center mais elle cache les
blessures invisibles
ce difficile je passais tous les jours
j'ai perdu beaucoup d'amis dans le world
trade center c'est vraiment dur
émotion dévoiler enfin dans l'église
saint paul le père dé soutenir au moment
des attentats
je suis venue spécialement cette semaine
pour me souvenir de tous ceux qui sont
morts ici il y a 6 ans
les commémorations comment souris si
dans quelques heures légèrement en
retrait de 20 0 raison des travaux en
cours seules les familles de disparus
pourront descendre et surveiller
quelques instants voilà pour les